-Can I shout out, right away,
give you a shout out
on something I enjoyed seeing?
-I won't stop you.
-You're on the cover
of the "GQ" Comedy Issue!
Look at you!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Issa Rae, Sarah Silverman,
our friend Kate McKinnon.
-Yeah, pretty cool to be
with those two gals.
It's nice.
-And it's a very funny cover,
because there's like, extra
limbs where there shouldn't be.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, because remember
when that happened?
-Yeah, there -- yeah.
-So they kind of --
we did that, but they --
these two actually
were in a different room
when we shot this,
so it was stranger number one
and stranger number two.
And they were, like, okay,
now put your leg on her head.
-Oh, funny.
-And now stick your legs
through her leg and then put
your hands up on to her thing.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, wow.
-So I got pretty close.
-And that's great.
-With strangers one and two.
Hey, guys.
[ Laughter ]
-You got to take a photo --
there's a photo shoot inside
where you have --
took a picture with an iguana,
a live iguana.
-Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-And you had -- is it true
that you had a pet iguana
growing up?
-No, I'm no stranger to iguanas.
[ Laughter ]
I had one from the years
15 to 16.
-That seems like a short period
of time.
-Well, you know, they're not
meant to live in suburban homes.
And they're even less meant to
participate in photo shoots.
[ Laughter ]
The guy was, like, "We've got
the iguana, her name's Angela.
I'm going to place Angela
on you.
Don't worry. They don't bite."
That's not true.
[ Laughter ]
'Cause I've been bitten by one
for 20 minutes once.
-Oh, so he didn't realize
he was dealing with
the rarest case of a cover --
a cover shoot model
who had actually owned
an iguana.
-Right, exactly.
But he was just, like,
"Angela, Angela,
look at the camera.
What are you doing?"
He would take the iguana aside,
"Listen, baby,
they need to see your face.
Why don't you look
at the camera?"
[ Laughter ]
It's an iguana. That's why.
-It's great when you have --
sometimes I've been on sets
where animal handlers show up,
and you think they're gonna
be like horse whisperers.
That they're going get
whatever animal they handle
to do the perfect things.
And then they do exactly
what you or I would do,
and be like,
"Come on! Just do it!
Don't worry,
I know how to talk to horses.
Do it!"
[ Laughter ]
-"Angela, don't climb.
Don't climb up her.
They're very safe.
They're very safe."
An iguana's got talons, okay?
[ Laughter ]
An iguana can rip flesh open.
-I had the most wonderful thing
happen.
We were at a wedding together.
We were at our friend
Aidy Bryant's wedding.
She married Conner O'Malley,
also our friend.
-It was the best wedding.
-It was a great wedding,
we sat next to each other.
And I gave you some advice,
and you actually took it.
-Yeah, well, you worked --
I was complaining to you
that I don't ever have time
to workout.
Time or the will, or impetus.
[ Laughter ]
And you were, like,
"well, I jog to work."
-I do.
-And when your workout
is your commute,
that saves a lot of time.
And I thought,
"Well, I'm going to do it, too."
So I've been running to work
for the past three weeks.
I did it every day.
-And it's working out.
-Yeah.
-What's the difference?
-The key thing
that you mentioned to me,
but sort of glossed over
was that you have a shower
in your dressing room.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Right.
So I have been "showering"
with a couple paper towels.
[ Laughter ]
Wet paper towels in the office
that I share with Aidy Bryant.
[ Laughter ]
And, gosh, I'm just praying,
'cause one of these days,
she's just going to walk in
and find me like --
[ Laughter ]
-No one wants that.
-No one wants it.
I don't want it.
She doesn't want that.